the audio technica ath m50s are among
the finest headphones under 200
and have been compared to headphones of
a much higher price and still come out
on top but on video
they've never been compared to monster's
very finest they're top of the line
beats pros until now so just as a
preview
i have the lowest prices i can find in
the description below this video but
as of right now the m50s run around 160
dollars
while monsters beats by dre run up
around 400
so with the build the m50s are a very
highly adjustable and pretty comfortable
pair of headphones actually i've worn
them for hours on end doing all kinds of
audio stuff
and they're pretty soft on the inside
and overall their build quality
is right where it should be the beats
pros are a very rigid pair of headphones
on the other hand you can see that
they're made
almost entirely out of aluminum so
they're very very sturdy but that means
that they also don't adjust as much
and they do try to make up for that with
this very very
very soft material on the headband and
in the ear cups
but they still hurt my head after
listening for a shorter period of time
than the n50s did
both pairs of headphones are adjustable
they have these little notches on the
side so you can adjust them to the size
of your head which is nice especially if
you have a huge head
or a massive never mind anyway one of
the weird quirks about the beach pros is
that they have
a rigid circular earcup which is not the
natural shape of the ear the m50s
actually fit
better with more of an oval ear cup and
another hardware difference between the
two that actually goes in favor of the
beats this time
is that the m50s don't have a removable
audio cable while the beats pros
have two audio jacks and a removable
cable which allows you to daisy chain
multiple headphones together and listen
to the same audio source
that being said the cables itself are
mostly the same
just the monster cable is red yes
red oh and the cable is a bit shorter
with the beats
and also just fyi the beats pros have a
special
feature that djs around the world will
probably
never use but they can swivel the ear
cups back as you can see
honestly it's not that hard to just
brush your hand back and move the ear
cup back without the hinge but
hey it's it's a feature for your for
your inner dj
no but i've honestly never seen someone
buy a pair of headphones for this
feature but hey
it could be you you could be that boss
you boss mode
boss level type bow status
bows okay i'm done both pairs of
headphones come with these soft carrying
pouches
the monster cable one being a little bit
more flashy red and black and everything
with the audio technica one being a
little bit more subdued just a chill
gray color
but when it really all comes down to it
people are in it for one
main reason and that's audio quality
that's why people spend hundreds of
dollars on headphones
is because they're trying to get better
sound quality generally and to be
perfectly honest
the m50s sound better than the beats
pros
i thought i was gonna get punched in the
face for saying that high five
or don't hit your screen just or thumbs
up on this video do you know how many
people i see walking around like this
like this and like this seriously really
they're not even plugged in you're
making these a 400
fashion accessory a 400 necklace
please don't do that i admit it in this
swag category these are hands down
amazing looking okay i gotta i can't do
this anymore these are amazing looking
headphones they are hands down
classy bravo these are sexy if you value
that category at all
yeah these are excellent headphones but
in every other category it's the m50s
that take the top mark
and that's really where the value comes
in is is when you really decide
how much you're going to spend on
headphones and where you're going to put
your money yeah that's what you want to
consider so what i'm asked which is
better
i generally recommend the m50s to people
who value sound the most so
the m50s have a very balanced very
accurate very crisp
punchy sound very rich bass these make
excellent studio monitors for people
who want to listen to music and hear
things that they've never heard in the
song before that were mixed in if you
value this
rock solid build quality and you don't
mind paying a little extra for the name
and you know you really don't like the
looks of the m50s
and you don't mind the slightly
overpowering bass or the lack of mids
and some of the comfort issues and you
don't mind the price premium
then you should probably go with the
beats pros either way this has been
mkbhd
if you like this video give it a thumbs
up that really does help me out and i
appreciate it
and just a quick shout out thank you
guys for all the people who have
subscribed to my videos over the past
couple of weeks it's been
quite an interesting growth pattern uh
but good to see you guys new people on
board
either way thanks for watching this
video and uh mkbhd
signing out peace
you